[Music]
what happened in the last case you were
with
Naro that was
good so it
wasn't we were too late there was
nothing we could
do I'm working on this new case a
missing scientist found on the edge of
the villages frozen solid
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you want it's been 6 years why
are you here because you both know what
really happened and you need my
help I've seen that
before years
ago fine I'm just going to do this one
thing work together to close this case
and that's it for the two of us it is so
you want in or
what burn eyeballs self-inflicted
wounds those men died before they
froze what the get out of here now you
okay she's not good with people she
cares
about what are we missing here with
someone out there on the ice
with the night country it takes us
one by one this isn't going to be
good I'm thinking stuff
bad
stuff I
know I feel
too I guess you're
thinking the worst part is
done it's
not finish what you
[Music]
started
theor
[Music]